et nous sommes donc à trappes au circuit
beltoise et on va les rejoindre patrice
qui se trouve sur le bord du circuit de
karting pour le défi du mois de la
rédaction
[Musique]
attention ouais ça c'est du clap c'est
le meilleur club de l'ouest
pas rivaliser
patrice vous êtes prêt à relever le défi
de la rédaction bon
on va bien voir
quelques mois avec éric fournier qui
nous accueillent bonjour bonjour à vous
recevoir ici sur notre circuit de deux
cartes déjà la discipline s'adresse à
qui est ce que il faut déjà être bien
connaisseurs avant de s'élancer sur la
piste sinon on va repartir ans m'a
forcément vous inquiétez pas si beau jeu
vous donner quelques petits conseils
avant de les reperdre surtout que la
piste est un tout petit peu glissante
donc il y aura peut-être quelques petits
pièges à éviter mais sinon dans le
principe non c'est vraiment ça s'adresse
à tout le monde puisqu'on peut
accueillir des du public et dès l'âge de
8 ans à bord du moment où ils ont la
taille mais il y avait un champion dans
les yvelines d'ailleurs qui était très
jeune willy a déjà quelques années
clément aura effectivement plus de
façons c'est vrai que dans le kart ça
commence de plus en plus tôt puisque
nous on est entrain de même des petits
qui sont dans la catégorie minime et qui
ont fait des bons résultats déjà cette
année voilà donc ça fait partie des
activités qu'on propose et là c'est le
circuit principal il ya deux circuits
c'est ça notre lavrova pour la petite la
petite compétition l'entrée ou parce que
je crois que c'est un petit challenge
entre vous vous allez faire sur la piste
dite compétition mais animations
d'accord et effectivement sinon l'un
d'eux une deuxième piste qui se trouve
un petit peu à un petit peu avant la
cause est arrivée qui est un petit peu
plus petit et laqué plus beaux dédié aux
loisirs animations voilà maintenant à
l'essai alors c'est bon pour l'équipe et
c'est par exemple
[Musique]
savourer bien
allez attention pas fait pour un
challenge sprint sur trois tours ok donc
wifi n'est pas qui vous êtes prêts
c'est pas tout ce qu'il fallait
vito pas de la patrie
nos problèmes
après le losc est venu
[Musique]
je fais ça pouvait très bien comme ça
le club nous sommes
sous patronage
ou dépression est faible
lee
[Musique]
félicitations patrice je suis parti en
dérapage à peu près partout parce que
patrice a caché son jeu et c'est sa foi
qui nous a pas tout dit et ça adam
patrice beunard marche aller dit encore
laure avril 2e et tu vas donc du coup
vous allez repartir avec
voilà incroyable félicitations patrice
merci beaucoup
félicitations c'est patrice qui
l'emportent
côté jeu partait pas favori
[Musique]